bonjour jérôme ravi de vous avoir dans
cette matinale berthet france on a les
deux meilleurs ce matin alors pour
convaincre allez les plus jeunes
électeurs certains partis ne manquent
pas d'imagination
allant même jusqu'à utiliser les sites
de rencontres de quoi s'agit-il mon cher
jérôme alors pour les étudiants visé par
la démarche peut-être de répondre à
cette question hautement philosophique
l'amour est il soluble dans la politique
et réciproquement pour le mouvement des
jeunes avec macron la réponse est
évidemment oui surtout s'il s'agit de
faire réélire le président et ce n'est
rien de dire que la proche de la saint
valentin a galvanisé l'imagination d'un
mouvement vivement travailler par saisir
au monde
souvenez-vous le week-end dernier nous
avions eu droit à ces affiches à la
tonalité très érotique qui n'était pas
sans rappeler certaines déclarations
récentes du président kita suscité chez
certains électeurs une furieuse envie
d'aller griffonné la fiche pour
compléter le choc en ce dont ne se sont
pas privés certains tweets hausse
est relancée cette semaine voilà c'est
la fiche donc on a très envie évidemment
on a rajouté deux mots 1 ça rappelle ce
qu'avait dit emmanuel macron et et cette
semaine c'était justement la saint
valentin en effet magali et tout cela
n'était qu'un hors-d'oeuvre carte de
l'envié à l'action il n'ya qu'un pas
franchi avec allégresse cette semaine
très exactement le 13 février
précisément la veille de la
saint-valentin c'est le moment que
choisi par les jeunes avec macron pour
dévoiler une stratégie pour le moins
disruptive comme on dit en macro ni
créer un profil premium sur trois
applications de rencontres en ligne avec
une affiche représentant un couple et un
slogan je vote et toi à noter qu'afin de
ratisser le plus largement possible la
fiche était disponible en trois versions
le couple en question pouvant également
être constitué de deux hommes ou deux
femmes les applications concernées
étaient bandol grinder est évidemment la
plus célèbre d'entre elles kinder une
campagne prévue pour durer du 14 février
au 4 mars date limite d'inscription sur
les listes électorales
car officiellement il ne s'agissait pas
de faire campagne pour emmanuel macron
oui d'inciter les utilisateurs à voter
lors de la prochaine présidentielle et
un avis pas forcément partagé par
thunder pas vraiment non si grinder n'a
pas réagi pour le moment et que bobonne
a juste annoncé vouloir suivre de près
l'initiative pour vérifier qu'elle est
conforme à ses conditions d'utilisation
kinder lui a clairement fait savoir
qu'il ne l'entendait pas de cette
oreille pour eux cela revient à créer de
gros faux profils pratique formellement
interdite sur la plateforme regardez
nous n'autoriserons pas les faux profils
y compris ceux créés dans le cercle de
campagne politique si de faux profils
sont créés nous prendrons des mesures
adéquates échec et mat donc pour les
jeunes avec la conjointe pas si sûr
magali car loin de jeter l éponge les
jam ont fustigé l'attitude de trine 2 la
jam
allons m allant même jusqu'à mettre en
cause tenez vous bien le sens civique de
l'entreprise écoutons leurs présidents
s'y poser un sticker incitant à
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
est considéré comme du prosélytisme
je me demande si ces applications ont
une absence de sens de la démocratie et
de la citoyenneté
alors les soutiens un président toujours
pas candidat 10 dorénavant compter sur
une centaine de militants pour inciter
personnellement chacun de leur match à
aller voter s'ils étaient détectés ces
comptes en cours est probablement aussi
les foudres de kinder déterminés à
empêcher toute incursion de la politique
chez lui signalons pour être complet
qu'il ya l'équipe de janick yannick
jadot pardon qui annonçait elle aussi
les opérations similaires connaîtront
probablement le même sort mais
évidemment ce sont les supporters du
président qui au moins deux prises et
attention c'est la rançon de la gloire
en tout cas l'un comme l'autre doivent à
présent méditer cette citation de
coluche homme politique c'est une
profession où il est plus utile d'avoir
des relations faisait aux morts et voilà
ce sera donc la phrase du jour une bonne
phrase d'ailleurs un pour ce qui va
venir puisqu'on va parler évidemment de
deux là
de nicolas bay qui est à officialiser
son ralliement à eric zemmour ce matin
merci en tout cas tous les deux merci
nicolas vidal et merci à vous a fait
vous